Resident Evil 7 biohazard this is the
brand-new Resident Evil game that just
came out Monday night if you were at
Game Stop in line like I was and I spent
nine hours and 38 minutes completing
this game that's about how long it took
me to playthrough according to the end
credits screen and I'm here to talk
about I don't normally review games but
if you've been watching my channel for a
long time you know that I do really
enjoy video games but I don't review
them anywhere near as regularly as I do
movies for games I prefer to review
games that I actually wanted to play I'm
a fan of the Resident Evil games I don't
love all of them some have been up and
down for me Resident Evil 5 and 6 were
for me personally kind of low points in
regards to the series but everything
from the 1st to the 4th and some of the
spin-offs like Resident Evil 0 I really
enjoyed and I also had a lot of fun with
the two Revelations games which I think
are pretty underrated but when I heard
that this game Resident Evil 7 was going
to be going a bit back to basics well
changing one specific thing that being
first-person I was pretty excited to see
what they were going to do with this
game especially since the subtitle is
biohazard which is the original title
for Resident Evil in Japan in this game
you play as a man named Ethan who lost
his wife about three years ago she's
been missing or presumed dead and when
he gets a cryptic message suggesting
that she might just be alive he goes to
the Baker family mansion to investigate
which was a colossal mistake because
this is essentially the video game
version of the last 15 minutes of Texas
Chainsaw Massacre this is the most
fucked-up family I have ever seen in a
video game I hated just about every
single one of them they're horrible
people and they don't die they just keep
on coming back over and over again and
that's one of the things about this game
that is a little frustrating but it's
kind of frustrating in a good way there
is a difference between true gamer rage
frustration hatred and frustration at
just not being able to complete
something that's really fun but you have
to keep doing it over and over again but
you're somehow in some weird stable
masochistic way actually enjoying the
experience I really like Resident Evil
seven I think this is the best entry in
the series since four it does go back to
the basics of more survival horror where
you have limited ammo and you have to
preserve it very carefully you better
get those headshots in because if you
don't you're going to run out of
ammunition really fast but it's not
quite like the Wii U game zombie you
where you have like nothing but a bat
for a really long time and if you die
you're just kind of screwed this game
does give you some help
you are able to find ammo and things
that you need quickly it's just that you
really have to ration it because if you
play poorly and just kind of shooted
everything then you're going to have a
really hard time with this game one clue
I will give you is that when there are
crates around and they have things in
them don't shoot them to open them use
your survival knife you can save all
your ammo that way that's what I did
throughout the entire game what I love
about this game is the atmosphere the
locations to build up the fact that a
lot of times when things jump out at you
there's no music accompanying it
sometimes it just happens and you're
like okay that happened you know I
played this game in surround sound so
that was awesome if you have surround
sound definitely play the game in that
because it really adds to the experience
when you're walking through this mansion
there are sounds behind you and all
around you that can really really screw
you up and there were a few times where
it actually got under my skin quite a
bit and a lot of that is due to the
extremely well rendered creepy locations
in this game there's more than just a
house I won't spoil it for you but
there's a lot more than just a house and
that was something I was really excited
about I really liked the use of VHS
tapes in this game you collect tapes and
you can put them into a VCR and then you
watch a video that gives you clues on
something that you are eventually going
to have to do and you can actually
interact with this video and take part
in the video so it allows you to figure
out various clues and things you're
going to eventually have to do in the
future to get the upper hand on the
Baker family and it's kind of cool to
watch them be like how are you doing all
of these things how do you know this
well because I watched a VHS tape
motherfucker but for me my favorite part
of all the Resident Evil games beyond
the scary creepy stuff is the puzzles
I've always really liked puzzle based
games there aren't as many in this game
which was a little disappointing my
favorite thing is when you find an item
you have to hold
up in front of a light and then maneuver
it around to create a shape that fits
into a painting that will open up into
some secret passageway I thought that
was really clever there are a few
puzzles but it's not as puzzle heavy as
I was hoping it would be if you're not a
fan of puzzles and games then you'll
probably be really happy with that
there's plenty of weird creatures I
don't want to call them zombies per se
it's a sort of different sort of almost
a medical spin on it which goes into
that title biohazard it actually feels a
little more viral than some of the other
Resident Evil games that felt more like
endless hordes of zombies and without
getting into spoilers the game does have
a really good way of messing with your
mind and it has a great way of calling
back to the past so that you can then
make the connections you need to
understand the story which by the way
this game has a fantastic ending I
really thought it was surprising and it
took me off-guard because I won't get
into it but there's a certain thing that
you encounter throughout the game that
sets you on edge and it's just kind of
there and you're like okay I guess maybe
at some point I'll have to deal with
that thing and sure enough you do and it
really added something to the entire
experience and I must say please read
all the files look at all the photos
look at everything find every little bit
of evidence you can explore every room
and every nook and cranny because it's
going to help you understand the story
more and when I played these games I'm
more of an explorer I really like to
look through everything I open every
single door that I can every single
drawer every single cabinet I look at
all photos I read all the newspaper
clippings everything because it really
adds to the experience this game has
successfully filled that void that I had
when I discovered that PT was no longer
going to be made a silent hill's game by
hideo kojima that was cancelled that was
one of the most disappointing
experiences in regards to a video game
I've ever had I was so ready for that
game and I think they actually have
filled that void for me because there is
a first-person perspective to this that
did feel very much so like PT at times
and I feel like maybe they were like hey
this isn't happening
let's help let's help the gamers out
there have some catharsis for what they
could have had and this game for
I filled that void the controls I
thought were very seamless all of the
combat felt extremely fluid I love the
amount of ammo that I was given it was
just enough if you ration it perfectly
the enemies were fearsome and scary the
locations were very well utilized and
extremely creepy I didn't really give a
crap about anybody in this game though
but I mean if you ever played a Resident
Evil game you know that that's not
really important it's really about you
feeling their experiences and becoming
them because you don't even really get
to see much of Ethan in this game it's
really about you becoming him and you
experiencing whatever he's experiencing
this is a really disturbing game that's
like a mishmash of Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
and what was hopefully going to be
silent hill's and it's all into one and
it's a ton of fun this is my favorite
Resident Evil game since four I'm going
to give Resident Evil biohazard a 9 out
of 10 I feel like I have to remind you
every time I do a video game review that
I do games out of 10 and movies are
letter grade because I just don't do
that many game reviews I hope you guys
check this out if you've never played a
Resident Evil game before I'd maybe
start with the HD re-release of the very
first one that is a bangin game tons of
fun and then eventually go on to like
you know two three four
you can skip five and six I would say
that's just me personally if some people
might really like them but I would say
just either play Revelations after that
or skip right to seven also I'm going to
be reviewing the last Resident Evil
movie this weekend or so it's being
marketed as the final chapter so look
forward to that guys you are the best
thank you very much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes
[Applause]
[Music]